[Music]
[Applause]
Pat 40 from Sports Illustrated joining
us the senior writer for Sports
Illustrated what's the committee telling
us about those
rankings well I think they did value
Ohio State's big victories over Notre
Dame and Penn State uh but the other
thing they're telling me Dan is that
they basically just slaughtered
Everybody by how many losses you have
the top five are all undefeated they're
The Undefeated ones in the power five
conferences the next eight are the eight
one loss teams in power five conferences
and then you get to the two lost teams
so strength of schedule as of now is
less important than how many times
you've lost give me the one lost team
you think that has the best chance of
being in the final four I think Oregon
uh because I like their chances to win a
rematch with Washington or whoever they
may face in the Pack 12 championship
game three point Point loss on the road
wild atmosphere kind of gave the game
away they've looked great since then
they're going to play some real high
quality games here down the stretch so I
think their their strength is schedule
going to be there and if they get in
with one loss to the to the clubhouse at
12- one I think they can make the
playoffs what's the knock on Georgia and
maybe it's not a big knock they are
second in the in the the country but
first half of the Season not formidable
consistently formidable I think two
things didn't play very many good teams
you know just n not a good
non-conference schedule and then
Kentucky was the only ranked team they
played they wiped the field with
Kentucky and now Kentucky doesn't look
that good so there's not that much on
the resume yet and then yeah they were
not they kind of slept walk through some
of those games early uh but now that the
schedule's going to ramp up considerably
they're playing ranked teams the next
three weeks in a row Missouri
Mississippi Tennessee and then you're
looking at an SEC Championship game
probably against Alabama maybe LSU so
they their strength of schedule will be
there I think if they keep winning they
will pass Ohio State but maybe not in
the end after Ohio State plays Michigan
we'll see what happens there give me the
uh team that is undefeated that will be
the first to have a loss of those
undefeated I think keep an eye on
Washington there good team had a great
season but they've struggled up late and
the schedule wow these next three weeks
uh really tough all playing ranked teams
two of the three on the road and if they
play the way those teams the way they
played Arizona State and Stanford
they're going to lose at least once if
not twice in that section what's Dabo
Sweeney saying in that rant that he had
on his radio show whether it's to the
fan base to his
players uh
alumni um you're lucky to have me is
what he is saying I don't think there's
any doubt about that that that he feels
that way um I think he's also he may not
say it out loud but he wishes it was
1992 you know where players didn't get
paid and there wasn't this crazy
transfer portal and y y yada uh but
that's the way it is and he hasn't
adapted well at all that's what he's
going to have to do he's going to have
to Modern his modernize his program
modernize his approach but that was very
much a you need to appreciate me for
what I've done this is Clemson and I won
two national titles let's have a little
respect can uh Caleb Williams how does
he play himself back into the Heisman
picture well he's got some good
opportunities starting this week I mean
him against Michael penck is going to be
a big time game and then they've got you
know they've still got uh Oregon State
on the schedule I believe they got UCLA
uh at the end there he's got some
high-profile opportunities they've just
they got to win the games and he's got
to play great and to win the games
you're going to have to make your make
sure your defense is something other
than horrible which there the the number
of points they've given them their last
five games is the most in a five game
stretch in USC history it's that bad but
I was wondering this start of the season
I knew the defense wasn't going to be
good I didn't know they'd be this bad
but he was always going to have to stay
in the game because they needed to score
therefore he was going to put up big
numbers I just didn't realize that
they're an average team they have a you
know obviously a great quarterback but
the team seems average yeah I mean
defensively they are not good the
offensive line uh leaky you know running
backs are just kind of pedestrian
they've got good receivers and the other
thing with I I feel like watching Caleb
that he's almost trying to make this
spectacular play all the time instead of
just making plays and you know you we've
all watched quarterbacks long enough Tom
Brady didn't make that many spectacular
plays but he made the right play all the
time and they won all the time because
of it we're talking to Pat 40 the senior
writer Sports illustrator covering
college football where are we with the
Michigan
story it's just that you know the daily
gift I mean what's it going to be under
the tree today and we'll see but the the
central Michigan Angle now is
fascinating the maybe probably Connor
stallions was on the sideline uh for the
central Michigan home or away opener at
Michigan State uh Jim M Wayne the
central Michigan coach last night
referred to him as the sign stealing guy
uh they haven't admitted that he was
there but it's clear it was him but is
he in Disguise as well it's like Bobby
Valentine being in the Dugout when he
got thrown out of a game in disguise so
this guy he's got a central Michigan hat
on and does he have a mustache or
glasses he's got a you know go te but
he's got he's wearing sunglasses it was
a night game he's wearing sunglasses
he's got the central Michigan coaching
Garb on how did he know what they were
going to wear where did he get the bench
pass from you can't tell me I'm I'm
unconvinced That central Michigan has no
idea how this happened let's put it that
way but how much trouble is Michigan and
Jim Harbaugh in I I don't think michig I
don't think Jim Harbaugh is in trouble
yet for this he's in trouble for the
other investigation yeah but you know
there hasn't been anything tying this to
him as of yet the question from an NCAA
standpoint is you start piling up
various level one violations and there's
a strict liability Rule now that that he
could get hit for but that's next year
like if you want to go Inn the national
title this year it's going to be
impossible for the NCAA to touch them I
don't think the Big 10 has a whole lot
of interest in doing it Michigan itself
certainly doesn't have any interest in
penalizing itself at this point and I
think that there's definitely efforts
underway to paint this as just wait hey
we got a psychopath on the staff who was
doing this stuff himself and that may be
the truth I don't know but we've got to
find that out but right now it's Connor
stallions on an island in Disguise
looking you know trying to do who knows
what yeah but why would you do this you
want acknowledgement from Jim Harbaugh
you want to prove your Worth to him
you're trying to be on the coaching
staff you want to be
elevated it doesn't make sense that
somebody's going to go Rogue and they're
probably going to paint him like he was
a rogue employee well he he was giv the
information to somebody yeah right
absolutely no I so like that's my
question did the rest of the Michigan
staff have no curiosity at all about
where Conor Steins was getting his sign
stealing information like is just hey
good stuff Conor keep coming or was it
hey are you doing this where are you
getting this yeah the other thing he's
pretty proud of himself he used to be on
social media and with his friends and
everything talking about what he was
doing as far as you know work for
Michigan and everything do we really
think that he wasn't bragging like hey
you know around the building look what I
got I I mean we don't have the proof of
that but human nature tells me that this
guy was probably talking to somebody
about you're not going to believe the
stuff I'm coming up with on Ohio State
on Penn State on Michigan state will
this affect the quarterback JJ
McCarthy's Heisman candidacy that iting
unfair Advantage right right I don't
think so but you know I mean the Heisman
Trophy has been called like the Nobel
Peace Prize of football you know where
you you everything has to be virtuous
and lovely and and wonderful and there's
a lot of stuff going on around Michigan
right now you know we'll see how they
play the rest of the way but I I don't
anticipate that becoming a voter issue
the last year the current College
playoff format how's the regular season
next year going to be affected uh it's
going to be this season on Rocket Fuel
it's going to be fantastic at this time
instead of having five unbeatens and you
know eight one loss teams we're looking
at and really probably only like three
one loss teams we're going to be looking
at like 20 25 teams that are going to
still have a chance to get into the
playoff and so I think the excitement
level for all the fans is going to be
more widespread there's going to be more
speculation more drama of hey you got to
win this game to stay in the playoff
contention now on the other side of it
the top teams will be able to lose a
game there's less at stake in individual
games you're going to be able to lose
and still get into the playoff but I
think there's just going to be more
excitement for more fan bases Nationwide
yeah I agree I remember when this came
out and there were some analysts said
this is bad for college football and I
go no you got more teams and and the
games in November are going to be
meaningful
you know that and maybe in SE like your
schedule and uh how you treat that if
you have a loss when you have a loss if
you have two losses can you still get in
could a three- loss team get in I think
brings in more fan bases for a longer
period of time and uh you know maybe
these Bull games actually mean something
yeah no doubt about it I I mean I think
that that there's just going to be a lot
of fascination with how this thing
unfolds and and yeah fans are going to
be I think eating up the you know the
mock brackets and how they look just
like they do in college basketball and
so there's just more involvement more at
stake for more teams and yeah people are
going to be sweating through all these
games in November instead of you know
just narrowing your focus yeah to a
small number it's going to be a much
wider number and then when we get campus
games and those first round on the
playoffs I think it's going to be
fantastic the atmospher are unbelievable
great to talk to you Pat thanks for
joining us my pleasure Dan thank you Pat
40 Sports illustrator yeah I think it's
wonderful I think the regular season
know and a lot of people said oh the
games aren't going to mean as much I
think there's going to be more games
that mean more